let's talk about uh
the the the absurdity that is um
hollywood in california and alec baldwin
we got the story from timcast.com
cinematographer's family files wrongful
death suit against alec baldwin the
santa fe sheriff's office is still
investigating the october 2021 onset
fatality but we have this story from the
new york post
alec baldwin sued by the family of
helene hutchins
they've released a video
it's kind of creepy
it is a cgi video
i can only show some of it because
youtube actually will probably shut us
down if i show you even though it's like
simulated
whatever man
it is what it is but i can you know i
can play a certain uh a decent amount of
it so let's let's play some of this
video
so this is important in understanding
the story about alec baldwin and the
shooting of helene hutchins let me slow
down and preface this real quick for
those are not familiar with exactly what
this is alec baldwin was on the filming
set of a movie called rust he shot a
cinematographer at first it was it was
declared a misfire it was an accident we
started to get more and more details and
it turns out that um based on the news
and the information that came out it
sounds much more like alec baldwin
intentionally murdered this woman at
least
a lot of people refuse to believe it i
certainly think it's more probable than
an accident because alec baldwin had a
single action revolver you had to pull
the hammer back you had to pull the
trigger to fire it it was loaded with
live rounds it was given to him by
someone who was not the onset armorer we
had nick cersei on the show who had
worked with that armorer before and said
she was great so all of this
just keeps coming back to there's no way
there's an accident but let me give you
that one very very important detail
before i show you this clip
alec baldwin claims that after he shot
this woman he didn't know she was hit
for 45 minutes
if you're standing in front of someone
and you point a gun at them pull the
hammer back pull the trigger he claims
he didn't pull the trigger but you pull
the hammer back and it goes off
and then they go ah and they collapse
and two people fall down what do you do
did alec baldwin just go all right and
walk away apparently cut cut yeah
everybody and they're screaming people
are screaming she's dying and he's just
like i didn't see anything my
cinematographer acts good yeah right
yeah he thought she was acting are they
filming her is she part of this so
here's let me play this clip now to show
you um
some of the some of the context around
here so here's the building
the reason why i think this is important
to go through is because a lot of people
are trying to imagine in their head what
it was like when this woman was shot you
can see here this is a it's all cgi by
the way this is what the building looks
like all right let's play a little bit
because now they're gonna take us inside
the building it's only about a minute
long this video
all right so there's the building we are
now going inside oh i think that was
that actually a photograph hold on oh
cool the first one
yeah so this is an actual switch is nice
right cool yeah is that it looks yeah
then it switches to cgi there you go all
right then we go inside
and this is what it looks like
inside uh this church on the set of this
film
alec baldwin is handed the gun
by the uh i guess associate director
assistant assistant director assistant
director
and then uh he sits down he's got the
gun in his uh in his holster and there
he is and i think now they're gonna show
they're gonna pan around
and you can now see
they're showing you where the
cinematographer was and
where the the uh the other director
right yeah the camera and i don't know
who those other two people are they
weren't named
crew yeah so here's what's interesting
i didn't i didn't realize this
how far away he was from her and the
crowd
and
that he pointed the gun straight at her
and not the camera because when we had
first talked about the story i was like
why would he point the gun straight at
the camera and people were like oh maybe
it was to get that shot or whatever
she's she's off to the his left of the
camera he points it straight at her and
he fires and he he killed her you
definitely killed her so he you were you
were you were arguing with me about this
initially like you can't say he he
killed her i don't know if i would call
it murder the intention is unknown he
definitely pointed the gun at the woman
pulled the trigger and killed her
whether or not he intended to i don't
know but i don't think that really is
what this is all about right now i mean
like look let's up for the courts to
decide let me show you this clip all
right we're not going to actually show
it because youtube will get mad at us
but he look at that five feet away from
her
or whatever it was and then he pulls the
hammer back and he shoots her wow now
here's the thing i'm gonna skip over the
part where she actually gets it because
that's you know
and you can see people rushing over to
help her and again cgi rendering of what
happened this is not actual video
evidence
where did alec baldwin go there's no
other exit to this building and he said
for 45 minutes he didn't know that she
got shot with a real bullet
so
he's like i thought she fainted or
something bro no if you point a gun at
someone and you pull the hammer back and
it goes bang and then someone screams
and collapses
why would you assume they must have
fainted he's a weak mind bro and he
wasn't able to accept what just happened
to him dude it was like shock what
happens when a soldier goes crazy in the
trench he knew he killed her he's just
shocked no ian you you that that's that
you you might as well believe in aliens
or he's just blatantly lying you might
as well believe if you're gonna tell me
that alec baldwin
pointed a gun
at a person from like five feet away
pulled the hammer back it went off in
his hand he felt the recoil the recoil
of a live round is different from the
recoil of a blank and then the woman
screams and the guy behind her screams
as well as they do in this video and
then people run over to help and he goes
must have fainted and then gets up and
walks off sorry i i would rather believe
that aliens took over his mind or the
mind control device that seems more
plausible to me then he was like i
didn't realize i had just shot them when
i pointed i got it pulled and pulled the
hammer back and it fired nah he he knew
what he did
that's why i keep hearing the story and
i'm like why would you assume anything
other than he put a bullet in the gun
and he shot her
the who put the bullet in the gun that
one i wonder hold on bro if you're going
to tell me
that it was the assistant director or
someone else who put the bolt in the gun
alec baldwin feeling the recoil of that
live bullet having trained with firearms
would have been like what yeah exactly
and then when she collapsed and screamed
he would have been like
what happened except he knew my life is
over my career is over and he probably
it all went through his head immediately
when he pulled the trigger and was like
it's too much for my brain
i mean that's a possibility i don't know
what that really happened people
is when someone is in a shocked moment
they don't have complicated thoughts
they have panicked thoughts and if alec
baldwin so you guys ever see sherlock
holmes
you ever see a game of shadows
no no so good i love it so they're
trying to find out there's a guy who's
got surgery to look like an ambassador
he's trying to trigger a world war
and so you know he's with watson and you
know watson's in the in the room and
they're like how do we find someone
who's pretending to be someone else
and then sherlock says
you know or i think it's watson who's
like
yeah sherlock's playing chess with
moriarty and watson's like do something
shocking because they're trying so hard
to maintain a facade they won't react
properly to a shock and so what he does
is he smacks the tray with champagne on
it the champagne shatters and everyone
in the room goes
but the one guy in disguise doesn't
flinch
because in his mind he's desperately
trying to maintain his persona so when
the shock happens he doesn't respond
properly like everybody else
so that's when i when i hear this story
when alec baldwin himself i mean he lied
about everything he was like she was a
friend she was a friend then he said i
didn't know her i never met her before
it's like this guy's full of it
the idea that he pointed the gun pulled
the hammer back it went off in his hand
first i got so many questions the recoil
of a live bullet compared to the blank
he knew he was holding it it went off in
his hand the woman screams and falls
down it severed her spinal cord and he's
like i didn't realize it happened and
what did he do get up and walk away yeah
that's that's bs bro dude he did it i
don't know i don't know if this is the
same but
i mean i i watched kyle written house
shoot somebody and kill them in
self-defense and i didn't pull that
trigger and that had an effect on me
like i will never forget that i will
never watch forget watching that like
the way that i i felt i saw it like i
watched
life leave this guy's eyes like
literally like on the floor like
so i just like when i hear like these
gun stories and i can't relate to this
like you know police officers or people
in the military that have actually shot
people i think that would be someone
good to ask you know but for me like
i've i've watched that and i don't see
how alec baldwin could come out and just
be like oh i thought she fainted like
that dude there's there's like even if
you're in shock because i'm gonna be
honest like when i watched when i
watched that dude get killed i was kind
of like in a state of of shock like i
was still collected i knew what was
going on but i was still kind of like
did i like i put it on twitter and i'm
like did
i just saw that
like i just saw that like it was just
like in my mind like i it couldn't leave
my mind like i i just don't see how you
could like shoot somebody
and just there's and then go directly to
i just thought she fainted there's an
indescribable feeling that i've talked
about before when i see people who get
mutilated or killed
and i don't have a word for it i can't
even really describe it it's a weird
feeling
i see i've seen a guy whose legs were
turned to uh well
i know i'm thinking the same thing i'm
not gonna get into it too much detail
but uh i've seen severe injuries
mutilation and death and there is a
feeling that you get watching a body be
carried away maybe it's just me maybe
not everybody's definitely not just you
no i know and you know i wonder if there
would be a word for the feeling you get
when you watch this if more people have
had the shared experience of witnessing
something like that exorcism but because
of the opposite of an exercise because
most people don't actually experience
that
there's no way to explain that word to
someone who's never experienced that
feeling
when i when i hear that alec baldwin
pulled out a gun and it went off and
shot and killed a woman
and that he just assumed she fainted i'm
like this man is a liar and knew exactly
what he did
because
you know what i'll i'll put it this way
there's a video on reddit right now i
love i love saying i'm about read it
right and it's a little girl and she's
got a gun and she's playing with it and
she puts the magazine in and she
pulls it back and chambers around and
then she's going like ooh and she's like
playing with the trigger and laughing
and then she releases the magazine and
smiles and laughs and then bang it goes
off because it was around in the chamber
and she goes
that's freaking out
when a live round is discharged from a
gun you don't just get up and go must
faint it and walk off
yeah you start freaking out the weird
part is in this video the the after he
fires the video goes dark and then comes
back up and alex not there like where
did he what happened he must just got up
and walked out then apparently that's
what happened and he was on the phone
yeah immediately he left and he got on
the phone and he said he's lying about
all of it is the problem he said i
didn't realize she got hit with a live
bullet for 45 minutes i thought she
fainted
something like that but what's bothering
me so much about this whole story is
motive
yeah what's the possibility of here what
do you mean what's the motive for him
shooting her the the crew had been
complaining the whole time
they had threatened to walk off set
before alex uh
alex alec baldwin is a hothead who's
gotten into fights with people in the
past i think he just settled the lawsuit
i could be wrong about that and here he
is
i think viva fry had a really great
explanation about this he was like
imagine you're alec baldwin seasoned
famous a-lister wealthy on a low-budget
production the industry is in distress
you've got kova and all these rules the
crew is complaining nonstop they're
threatening to walk off
then you get the cinematographer who's
telling you what to do but this is not
the director you don't take orders from
her but she won't stop nagging see alec
baldwin said she was what do you call
her very like direct or something yeah
he wasn't saying about her that she was
a friend and nice to work with he said
she was like forceful effectively i
think the motive is simple
he was pissed off she was causing
problems she was jamming up the set and
the perfect opportunity to murder
someone is in a movie set where you're
supposed to have a gun but hold on a
minute in this lawsuit they're like why
wasn't using a rubber gun
why did he have a live
single action revolver with a with it
with with real ammo in it with a real
bullet at least
when they were when they were doing it
was like test filming
none of it makes sense unless of course
alec baldwin was like i am sick of this
woman she is causing problems for my
movie set and the easiest way to kill
somebody is to say it's an onset
accident
bang
none of his story makes sense and i'll
tell you this i'd be willing to believe
there was a conspiracy to commit murder
between him and the assistant director
before i believed this was an accident
for this to have been an accident you
have to believe in magical fairy tales
that the armorer who alec baldwin knows
is supposed to be the only one handling
the weapon didn't do it that somehow
live bullets got into it that somehow
alec baldwin forgot all of his training
that somehow alec baldwin or the singer
single action revolver pulled the
trigger back and with his finger out of
uh not on the trigger it went off
because that was testified to by the
assistant director so now you've got a
you've got a broken sear and a single
action revolver that he pulled he pulled
the hammer back his finger was off the
trigger it went off he didn't realize a
bullet was in it despite 40 years of
plus of weapons training against someone
he had every reason to be upset with nah
dude get out of here with that you know
i've been saying this from the beginning
i think he killed that woman i'll i'll
rephrase that i think it is
substantially more likely he killed this
woman on purpose then he killed her on
accident so if i say he did kill her
yeah negligent homicide i think at the
very least
um my i have a very similar take on
yours except that i think he was just
very angry with her and didn't like her
and was fantasizing about killing her
and there happened to be a bullet in the
gun that's ridiculous
it just doesn't make sense that he would
throw everything away just to try and
smoke it no he's not throwing it away
look at this he's not even gonna be it
destroyed his career we don't destroy
his life dude he's destroyed his life
but yeah under your scenario he's such a
psychopath like a total psychopath that
he didn't run even the most minimal cost
benefit analysis for what he was about
to do
he's a hothead
no not a hothead like anybody could be a
little bit of a hothead this guy must be
a psychopath to make that poor
absolutely poor cost-benefit analysis or
um or there was a potential for a
lawsuit that was going to cost some more
money
so we shot her i don't know it still
doesn't add up for me i don't know i
think that's true i mean he's getting
going by several people i'm glad that
it's going to court and i hope that the
in in criminal charges yeah we don't
look they are i'll tell you this there
are criminal charges no this is the
first deferred i don't think so this is
a civil case right there's no criminal
families right not yet i'm gonna i'm
asking oh yeah the point is you're
saying it's going to court i'm saying
you're saying it was a miscalculation
what do you mean he if he walked out up
to this woman in the middle of new york
avenue and pulled out a gun and shot her
he'd be in prison what if two 18 year
olds are sitting there one picks up a
gun and points to the other one and
shoots him and kills him and he's like i
didn't know there was a bullet in it
like we were acting for a movie they'd
be like shut up you're under arrest yeah
if they had a camera on and they thought
they were acting and then alec baldwin
doesn't he doesn't turn his man over for
how long that's kind of where i'm
thinking is like is it really
far-fetched to believe that alec baldwin
like
believes that he's above all of this
yeah it's not far fetched i think he
does what i'm saying like do you like do
we really sound crazy saying i think
alec baldwin thinks he could publicly
get away with murder saw the sympathy
crap videos he put out in the
following look let me just say
there's a potential for a motive in that
we've we've heard that people were
walking off set that people were
complaining that she was part of the
crew and the crew was really really
upset and it's frustrating for this guy
who thinks he's so big and he's an
a-lister she's not the director but
she's giving him orders and telling him
what to do and he's getting frustrated
those make sense the reality is there
could be an infinite number of reasons
for a motive maybe he had an affair with
her
oh no you know hilaria's gonna find out
maybe some it could be it could be as
simple as that we don't know the fact is
the story of how this went down you'd
have to be an absolute [ __ ] to believe
the way they've described it he was
accidentally given the gun by the wrong
person even though even though he knows
and has stated already in interviews it
has to come from the armorer but he let
it come from the other guy instead and
then he took the gun didn't check it
even though he knows you're supposed to
check the gun it's supposed to be
displayed for you he's stated all of
those things he's the one who said
you're handed a gun and it's they open
it up they explain it to you and then
you know if you fiddle with it in any
way so they're like why don't you check
it well if i did check it they take it
away from me
that makes no sense like it's an obvious
lie
but let me just make it simple for
everybody go out to a shooting range all
right
talk to an instructor
have them teach you and and and and
bring some blanks and fire a blank
and then fire uh you know what what what
was the caliber of the gun was what was
it wasn't a 45 was it i don't know i
don't know what it was i don't recall
but just just just uh get a difference
of the blank and the real bullet the
feel you're gonna be like wow this one's
obviously the blank and this one's
obviously the real gun so i do think it
was a murder just because he just shot
her and apparently had good enough aim
because we just saw in louisville
louisville how it's pronounced this guy
attempted to louville um he attempted to
shoot somebody really close range and
still ended up missing him for alec
baldwin to hit this lady
dead to rights that was incredibly
intentional and think about it it was
straight in the center of her chest so
that it hit her spine too yeah that's
intense and went through and hit the
director yeah he shot two people
check this out it went straight to the
center of her chest
and through her spine that's spot on so
this is
we're talking about
winning a lot like winning three
lotteries in a row week after week after
week
that he had the wrong gun he wasn't
supposed to be using that he wasn't
supposed to point it at her there wasn't
supposed to be a bullet in it that his
finger was off the trigger and he pulled
the hammer back but the hammer went off
anyway and then the bullet it missed but
it went perfectly into the center of her
chest and ripped her spine apart then he
said i didn't realize i hit her and got
up and walks away yeah get out of here
man
people
you know no i'm not playing that game he
did it he murdered her it was on purpose
that's my opinion that is my opinion
now is it up to them to press like
charges
uh they have yeah that was that was the
basis of the lawsuit not the civil
charges i mean like criminal charges who
charge who files that the state does and
what are they so you think they're
waiting on it because alec baldwin's
alec baldwin
so as everyone's already predicted alec
baldwin will pay some some fat
settlement and he'll never see a day in
jail
that's the way it works in this country
well i think that then his motivation
for thinking that he could do it and get
away with it was entirely correct and
that would be perfect motivation to do
that if you got sick of somebody you're
like boy i think i can get away with
this watch me i got an idea for a movie
rust two the making of rust
i'm sure that's coming he'll be the
victim of the movie you know i got to be
honest i'd love to make a really really
um
a sketch a really great movie trailer
sketch and bad taste
about this
this whole thing russ too the making of
rust yeah
i have no sympathy for this her her
family right now they're not following
through taking this guy down in his
entire production crew they're suing him
i mean taking him down i don't he has
tons of money he'll pay it out
what do you think is what do you think
they're going to do put them in prison
for 30 years they don't do that the
state doesn't in prison for a year
judges
does this yeah but i mean
where's the pressure from the family
where's the guy standing up saying he
just belongs in jail he killed my wife
he's thinking i'd rather just get the 60
million dollars he should get both
it's up to him what he wants it's not
going to come from the family to get to
get legal
uh criminal justice
the state decides people need to
understand this um i don't know if it's
true for every state i think it is
there have been so many so many
instances where
someone will file charges like they'll
get attacked
and then the police will arrest a person
and they'll file charges against the the
person got arrested and then the other
person says i don't want to press
charges i want to withdraw and the cops
will be like you aren't pressing charges
we are it's the state versus mr smith
not you know jane doe versus john doe
we don't need you as a witness because
we already have your medical records
showing the attack occurred bye-bye
so it doesn't matter what the
individuals want but typically when
someone refuses to press charges if they
say i don't want to press charges what
they're really saying is i'm not going
to be a cooperating witness for the
state and the state will likely lose
then and so then the state says okay get
out of here we're not going to we're not
going to move forward there's no
complaint and not to mention that like
do you really want to be a prosecutor
who's like i've got no witness no victim
so it's just conjecture
and i'd rather not file the paperwork to
be completely honest right is that
that's probably what's going to happen
in this world go to court they've got a
lot of eyewitnesses
i can't imagine none of them would
testify considering all of the different
lawsuits against alec baldwin and his
company you'd think there'd be criminal
charges against him instantly for doing
this
like i don't care what the reason is but
that's what i'm saying it's it's why i
think
one of the things about this is a
perfect crime
alec baldwin wants to kill someone do it
on a movie set you'll never see it
you'll never see a day in jail
russ two the perfect crime yes i like
that that's pretty good yeah we gotta
make that happen damn and then whenever
we show alec baldwin it should be like
grainy black and white with like a
thunderstorm behind him and he's like
yeah like a horror movie
yeah and then like there's children
again is he real big you know with the
lightning striking behind him
now is your time to die no
oops it was an accident you know what i
will continue to mock this shooting
until they file criminal charges against
that guy dude it's so crazy man
it's it's it's mainstream celebrity it's
political it's the establishment it's a
big club and you ain't in it but i'm
glad to see that club falling apart to
be honest
you know
yeah maybe some things will change so i
want to talk about roblox oh well no i
got we have this other story i'll just
mention really really quickly from
buzzfeed a rust crew member texted a
warning about accidental gun discharges
days before alec baldwin fatally shot
helena hutchins this is super unsafe i
mean we knew the story but
the more i see this stuff the more it
just pushes me towards i think they set
this thing up
like alec baldwin's story is so half
brained and like insane and
contradictory then i'm like i see this
and i'm just like
i don't believe any of them
i don't believe any of them man
i think alec baldwin
you know so so one thing one thing i
think we just heard recently with nick
cersei though is they had a crew and
beaker or something like that because of
covenant a b and c yeah so they had you
couldn't be in the same room depending
on your crew or whatever a could only be
in the room with other a's and b and c
had to be out of the room that can
explain why it was that the armorer
wasn't the one who gave the weapon to
alec baldwin it could but it doesn't
explain why alec baldwin threw away his
training why he didn't realize he just
shot and killed a person
shot dead center through the chest and
through the spine and he was like i
thought she fainted just like walks away
it's like yeah those are the dead
giveaways plus he's on the phone no no
he was on the phone right away right
yeah so what someone faints so you get
on the phone right away with somebody i
don't know if it was right away how long
i don't know how long between the
shooting and him on the phone but i'm
pretty sure there's pictures of him on
the phone outside like after it happened
i don't know if it was within a minute
or within 20 minutes and then he didn't
turn his phone over he refused to turn
his phone over probably because of his
conversation did he eventually do it
exactly yeah exactly why why somebody he
called something he was setting up
it has been done the weaving of a
conspiracy is starting to make a little
bit more sense yeah i'm actually crying
right now for the cameras they're taking
pictures of me as i'm talking to you
yeah well the conspiracy theory is that
this helena hutchins woman was a
journalist before she got involved in
cinematography and she was doing these
investigations
so
the conspiracy theorists think that she
was still actively investigating
something and that she was taken out
yeah i don't know about any of that
stuff man
i think it's enticing though yeah i
think you got a story of a hot-head
movie star he's pun he shoved a guy in
the street and got sued over it he
screamed at his kid and called her a
little piggy pig or something like that
little pig and so he's known for having
a bad temper
we know the crew was fighting with him
he lied several times about his story
isn't it just a simple solution that
sometimes people commit murder
yeah
it's uh
well yeah that is a simple solution
applying it to this is a little more
complicated because we don't know where
the bullet came from i want to know
that's why i'm saying he committed a
murder it came from him he got a bullet
he put it in the gun yeah why was he
using a real gun that's the simplest
solution gotta get the shot and what i
mean is the camera angle it's gotta look
right on cameras what i mean i gotta get
the shot the lawsuit is flat out saying
that they have prop guns for test
filming
like actual replicas
and rubber guns
why was using a real single action
revolver with live ammo in it
okay
maybe what happened was uh the assistant
director hated helena and set uh alec up
and and broke the seer on per this here
is the piece inside it holds the hammer
back he broke it on purpose and that's
why he said alec baldwin's finger was
off the trigger and he pulled the hammer
back and it went off
on a functioning single action that
wouldn't happen
but maybe it was an old weapon and the
seer had been worn down and wasn't
working properly hm so when he pulled
the hammer back it just released right
away and slammed that's gross negligence
by the production company if that's what
the case was the handing alec
a messed up gun is is negligence no what
what gets me is all the people on
twitter who are who defended alec
baldwin when i was tweeting about it and
they're like clearly you don't know
anything about how movie sets work and
i'm like um i do
whenever you hand someone a gun
it is the responsibility of the person
holding the gun period no matter what at
all times don't care yeah that brings
back to my question if two 18 year olds
have a camera set up in their living
room and one pulls up a gun and she
points it and shoots it and there's a
bullet in it does that kid go to prison
or guys 20 year olds of course
just because there's a movie camera on
doesn't matter
he should have checked the gun
right should have done a lot of things
but here we are man i don't know what a
crazy story ian came came in here and he
was like there's a video of it and i was
like no because everybody was saying
they filmed it right they filmed what
happened
oh literally they're filming right well
they might have been between takes i
don't know if it was rolling you guys
got to watch this video by the way
no it's a cgi
um and there's music which is a little
manipulative you know makes it creepy
but just watching the flow of it it just
looks so blatant on alex part
thoughtless and blatant i mean the video
they made shows alec just sitting there
and then he grabs the gun and goes bang
and shoots her it might have been like
manchurian candidate yeah lifeless eyes
it's pretty uh accurate on that pretty
wild yeah it just shows sitting there
it's like a perfect rendition of his
face yeah perfectly calm
looks like he's plotting something yeah
i think i think the story is important
because it shows how people who are
aligned with the establishment can uh
just basically get away it shows how
coveted restrictions can mess up a movie
site so you can't have your armor on set
with your with your acting a team
apparently if that's possible they have
an a b and c team which is completely
unethical for someone to put those
people in that position of danger where
the armor can't deliver the gun to the
actor
yeah if that's the case
there's a lot of things that this is
blown out of proportion and that
production company is liable for her
death
for her that's why everybody's getting
sued but you can't squeeze blood out of
a turnip they're already on a low budget
production so i don't know what they're
gonna have left anyway
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you